Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd'hui on va parler du deep learning.
Le deep learning c'est un domaine
de l'intelligence artificielle
qui a littéralement explosé ces dernières années.
Vous en avez déjà peut être entendu parler
si vous avez vu ma vidéo sur le Go,
ou bien si vous avez vu, il y a quelques mois, ces images
un peu psychédéliques qui ont été publiées par Google
et qui représentaient soit-disant un algorithme
de deep learning en train de rêver.
Alors aujourd'hui on va voir
ce que c'est que le deep learning
et comment ça se positionne par rapport
aux autres champs de l'intelligence artificielle.
L'intelligence artificielle on en parle
depuis plus de 50 ans maintenant
et l'histoire du domaine est un peu tumultueuse.
Ça a commencé par une période
de grand enthousiasme
où on s'imaginait qu'on arriverait très vite
à faire des choses assez incroyables.
Puis ça a été suivi par une période
un peu plus sombre de désillusion
où on a finalement constaté qu'on avait
un peu sous-estimé les difficultés.
Je ne vais pas vous refaire l'histoire du domaine
mais ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est que dans les années 90,
après cette période de désillusion,
Il y a eu une renaissance de l'intelligence artificielle,
sous la forme de ce que l'on appelle
le machine learning,
ou "l'apprentissage automatique" en bon français.
Le machine learning c'est un domaine qui étudie
comment des algorithmes peuvent
apprendre en étudiant des exemples
et on va voir exactement ce que ça veut dire.
Le deep learning dans tout ça,
ou "l'apprentissage profond"
c'est juste une manière particulière
de faire du machine learning
et je vais vous expliquer en quoi elle est originale
et pourquoi elle a explosé ces derniers temps.
Pour comprendre comment des ordinateurs et des
algorithmes peuvent apprendre à faire des choses
on va partir d'un exemple très très simple.
Imaginons que vous soyez un botaniste
et que vous vous intéressiez à
une certaine espèce d'arbre.
Vous vous promenez en forêt et
vous faites des observations
et sur chaque arbre que vous croisez
vous relevez sa auteur et le diamètre de son tronc.
Puis vous consignez toutes vos observations
dans un tableau de données.
Voilà le tableau, chaque ligne
représente un arbre différent
dont vous avez mesuré le diamètre et la hauteur.
Une chose simple que l'on peut faire
quand on a des données comme ça
c'est de les représenter graphiquement.
On met le diamètre en abscisse, la hauteur en ordonnée
et chaque point va représenter un arbre
différent que vous avez mesuré.
Voilà ce qu'on obtient.
Vous avec vos yeux et votre cerveau d'être humain,
vous voyez qu'il y a un truc notable dans ces données.
Tous les points sont, en gros, à peu près alignés
et on a très envie de faire passer une droite.
Faire passer une droite comme ça c'est vraiment une
bonne idée parce que ça nous permet de généraliser,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a un certain nombre d'observations
sur des cas particuliers,
qui sont les arbres qu'on a mesurés,
et on en tire une relation générale qui est cette droite.
Et grâce à ce lien qu'on a découvert dans les données,
on va pouvoir faire de la prédiction.
La prédiction ça veut dire que
si je prends un nouvel arbre
de la même espèce qu'on n'a pas encore mesuré
et que je vous donne son diamètre,
vous pouvez grâce à cette droite estimer sa hauteur.
Le terme de "prédiction" est peut être un peu mal choisi
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas de prédire l'avenir,
il s'agit plutôt de deviner une valeur qu'on ne possède pas.
Donc je résume la démarche : on prend des données
qui sont des observations particulières,
on découvre un lien dans ces données
et ce lien nous permet de généraliser,
de faire des prédictions.
Ici, on a tous les ingrédients
de ce qu'est le machine learning.
Le machine learning, c'est essayer de faire
la même chose avec des algorithmes.
En supposant qu'on prenne ces mêmes données
et qu'on les donne à un ordinateur,
on peut très bien imaginer un algorithme
qui va chercher comme nous
à faire passer une droite parmi les points.
Une droite est définie par deux choses : Une pente : a
et une ordonnée à l'origine : b
Vous savez, c'est le classique : y = ax + b.
On peut imaginer un algorithme qui fasse varier a et b
jusqu'à trouver une droite qui
colle bien au nuage des points.
Souvent l'image qu'on prend c'est d'imaginer
que a et b, les paramètres de la droite,
c'est un peu comme deux boutons
que l'algorithme peut faire tourner
jusqu'à trouver la meilleure droite possible.
Et une fois qu'on a fait ça, on ne touche plus
à nos deux boutons et on a une droite
qui permet à l'algorithme de généraliser,
d'extrapoler à des cas qu'il n'a jamais vu.
Il suffit d'utiliser l'équation de la droite.
Et voilà, le machine learning, en gros, c'est ça.
On a des données, ici sous la forme
d'une entrée X et d'une sortie Y,
on les présente à un algorithme
qui a des boutons et qui les tourne
jusqu'à ce qu'il ait compris le lien entre X et Y.
Ça, c'est tout ce qu'on appelle la phase d'apprentissage.
Et puis, une fois que c'est fait,
on peut faire des prédictions
et ça, c'est le but ultime d'un algorithme
de machine learning,
être capable de faire des prédictions,
des extrapolations.
Evidemment, ici, j'ai pris un exemple super basique.
En entrée on n'a qu'un seul nombre X
qui est le diamètre de l'arbre,
en sortie, un seul nombre Y qui est sa taille
et en plus le lien entre les deux est très simple,
puisque c'est une simple droite.
Mais dans les vrais problèmes de machine learning,
on peut avoir des relations qui sont
beaucoup plus compliquées
et surtout, on peut avoir beaucoup plus
qu'une seule donnée en entrée.
Pour le voir, on va prendre quelques exemples
d'applications du machine learning.
Vous avez certainement déjà remarqué que
votre fil Facebook ne vous montre pas
toutes les nouvelles de vos amis ou
des pages auxquelles vous êtes abonnés.
Il en choisit seulement certaines et il
vous les présente dans un certain ordre.
Derrière, il y a un algorithme de machine
learning qui essaie de comprendre
quelles sont les nouvelles qui ont
le plus de chance de vous intéresser.
Cet algorithme prend en entrée tout
un tas de caractéristiques de la nouvelle,
qui l'a postée ? quand ?
de quoi elle parle ? sa nature, etc...
Et il essaie de prédire si ça va vous intéresser ou pas.
Un autre exemple d'utilisation du machine learning,
c'est la détection de fraudes sur internet.
Chaque fois que vous utilisez
votre carte de crédit sur internet,
il y a un algorithme quelque part qui tourne
pour essayer d'estimer si c'est
bien vous ou si c'est une fraude.
Pour ça, il utilise des données d'entrée
qui sont la nature de la transaction,
sa localisation, son montant et tout
un tas d'autres données du même genre.
Encore un autre exemple d'utilisation
du machine learning
dont on va particulièrement parler aujourd'hui,
c'est la reconnaissance d'images.
La reconnaissance d'images, ça consiste
à essayer de faire un algorithme
qui prend en donnée d'entrée une image,
et dont le but est d'essayer de deviner,
en sortie, ce que représente l'image.
Vous voyez peut être sur ces quelques exemples
que ma droite ax+b avec ses deux boutons
va être largement insuffisante.
Il nous faut quelque chose qui soit capable
de prendre plein de données d'entrée
et surtout de capturer des relations bien plus
complexes que ça entre les entrées et la sortie.
C'est là qu'interviennent les réseaux de neurones.
Un neurone c'est quelque chose qui va jouer
le même rôle que ma droite tout à l'heure,
c'est à dire que c'est une fonction mathématique
qui va mettre en relation des entrées X avec une sortie Y.
Alors évidemment, c'est important de préciser
que ce dont on parle là c'est un neurone artificiel,
c'est à dire que c'est une construction mathématique
qui imite grossièrement
le fonctionnement d'un vrai neurone.
Les vrais neurones biologiques ce sont des cellules
qu'on trouve dans notre système nerveux
et qui sont connectées les unes aux autres.
Chaque neurone possède une terminaison
qu'on appelle un axone
et par laquelle le neurone peut envoyer
un signal à d'autres neurones.
La manière dont fonctionne un neurone, est la suivante :
Le neurone reçoit, ou pas, un signal électrique
des autres neurones qui sont connectés à lui
et en fonction de ces signaux,
il fait un truc assez binaire.
Soit il n'envoie rien dans son axone,
soit il envoie un signal électrique,
et là on dit qu'il "décharge".
L'idée du neurone artificiel qui date
déjà d'il y a plusieurs décennies,
c'est de mimer ce comportement
par une fonction mathématique.
Voilà le principe, imaginons qu'on ait
un neurone artificiel avec trois entrées,
on va les appeler X1, X2 et X3.
On fait la somme de ces trois entrées
en affectant un coefficient à chacune,
on appelle ça un poids.
Si la somme obtenue est supérieure à un certain seuil
le neurone va envoyer 1 en sortie, sinon il va envoyer 0.
Un neurone artificiel, vous voyez donc
que c'est une fonction mathématique
qui prend des X en entrées et sort un Y en sortie
et cette fonction elle a des boutons qu'on
peut tourner, qui sont les poids et le seuil.
Un peu de la même manière qu'on pouvait
changer les coefficients a et b sur la droite.
Le problème, c'est qu'un neurone tout seul ne
suffit pas pour faire des relations très compliquées.
Ce qui est intéressant c'est que les neurones
on peut en associer plein ensemble
et les empiler pour faire des fonctions
beaucoup plus compliquées
et c'est ça qu'on appelle des réseaux de neurones.
On devrait plutôt dire des réseaux
de neurones artificiels.
En empilant des neurones comme ça on peut fabriquer
des fonctions aussi compliquées qu'on veut
avec plein d'entrées et plein de sorties
et surtout plein de boutons à tourner,
autant que de poids et de seuils dans le réseau.
Ces réseaux de neurones, l'avantage
c'est qu'ils sont très polyvalents,
on peut les adapter à plein de
types d'entrées ou de sorties
Mais, dans le fond, on les utilise de la
même manière que ma droite, tout à l'heure.
On prend un réseau de neurones,
on lui présente une base de données
d'exemples d'entrées et sorties
et on tourne tous ses boutons jusqu'à ce qu'il fasse
correctement le lien entre les entrées et les sorties.
Je vous rappelle qu'on appelle ça
la phase d'apprentissage.
Et, une fois qu'on a fait ça, notre réseau est entraîné
et il est capable de prédire la sortie
si on lui présente une nouvelle entrée.
Ça, c'est la phase de prédiction.
Un des inconvénients des réseaux de neurones
par rapport à ma droite de tout à l'heure,
c'est que c'est ce que l'on appelle
parfois un modèle "boîte noire".
C'est à dire qu'une fois qu'on a trouvé
toutes les bonnes positions des boutons,
on se retrouve avec une fonction qui
mathématiquement est un peu compliquée
et c'est un peu difficile de l'interpréter.
Mais bon, en général tant que le réseau de neurones
donne la bonne réponse on est content.
Et d'ailleurs il semblerait que l'apprentissage
dans le cadre des réseaux de neurones artificiels
ressemble pas mal à ce qui se passe
en réalité dans le cerveau.
Quand on apprend des choses, la force des connexions
entre nos neurones se modifie,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'efficacité synaptique
et ça peut se comparer à la manière dont on joue sur
les poids dans notre réseau de neurones artificiels.
Encore une fois, le but des réseaux de neurones
ce n'est pas de faire un modèle de notre cerveau,
c'est juste une construction
mathématique qui s'en inspire.
Tout ça c'était pour la théorie,
maintenant on va passer à la pratique.
On l'a dit, quand on veut faire un réseau de neurones, on empile plein
de fois cette unité élémentaire qu'on appelle le neurone artificiel.
Une question : combien faut-t-il en mettre dans notre réseau ?
Si on s'inspire de notre cerveau, il y a
à peu près 100 milliards de neurones
et comme il peut y avoir plusieurs milliers
de synapses pour chaque neurone
ça ne nous met pas loin du million
de milliards de connexions.
Très clairement, on ne va pas pouvoir faire ça
avec un réseau de neurones artificiels.
Sans aller jusque là, dès qu'on met
trop de neurones dans notre réseau,
ça fait beaucoup trop de boutons qu'on peut tourner,
et ça devient très difficile de trouver
les bonnes positions des boutons.
Ça veut dire que la phase d'apprentissage
devient quasiment impossible.
C'est pour ça qu'en pratique on se limite à une structure
très simple avec seulement 3 couches de neurones.
Les neurones d'entrée, qui sont les X,
le ou les neurones de sorties, c'est le Y
et puis une couche intermédiaire de neurones.
Plus on met de neurones dans la couche intermédiaire,
plus le réseau est polyvalent et puissant
mais plus il devient compliqué à entraîner,
à trouver les bonnes positions des boutons
et si on essaie d'ajouter des couches de plus on se noie
assez vite dans la complexité de la phase d'apprentissage.
Pour des problèmes avec un nombre
raisonnable de données d'entrée,
comme par exemple de la détection
de fraudes sur internet,
ce genre de méthode peut très bien marcher
mais pour faire de la reconnaissance
d'images, c'est vite limité.
Si on prend une photo de petite taille : 400x400,
ça fait tout de suite 160 000 pixels,
c'est à dire 160 000 nombres à filer en entrée au réseau.
et on se retrouve obligé d'utiliser
un réseau extrêmement compliqué
qu'on n'arrivera pas à entraîner.
Donc, en somme, balancer une image brute
dans un réseau de neurones ça ne marche pas.
Heureusement il existe une méthode
pour s'en sortir, c'est celle de fabriquer
des caractéristiques intermédiaires de l'image.
Imaginons qu'on s'intéresse à un
problème qui consiste à reconnaître des véhicules.
Vous voulez fabriquer un algorithme
à qui on donne une image
et qui nous dit si cette image représente
une voiture, un bus, un train, une moto, etc...
Nous en tant qu'être humain, il existe
un certain nombre de caractéristiques
qui nous permettent de faire la différence.
On peut par exemple compter
le nombre de roues apparentes,
regarder le rapport largeur hauteur,
regarder quelle est la couleur dominante,
la quantité de surfaces vitrées, le
nombre de vitres, leurs formes, etc...
La solution pour faire de la reconnaissance
d'images dans ce genre de situation
c'est de créer un algorithme intermédiaire
qui ne sera pas un réseau de neurones
et dont le but va être d'analyser les images et
d'extraire toutes ces caractéristiques intéressantes.
Ce sont ensuite ces caractéristiques qu'on va donner
à un réseau de neurones pour faire la reconnaissance.
Cette approche peut fonctionner parce que la quantité
de données d'entrée qu'on va filer au réseau
va être bien inférieure à ce qu'on aurait
si on avait filé l'image brute en entier.
Les caractéristiques qui résument l'image, il va y en
avoir quelques dizaines, maximum quelques centaines
et comme on a résumé image en la réduisant
à une liste de caractéristiques essentielles,
on dit parfois qu'on a fait une abstraction de l'image.
Tout ça c'est très bien, mais ça pose
quand même un petit problème, c'est que
la qualité de la reconnaissance va
fortement dépendre de la manière dont
on a fait ce travail intermédiaire de construction
des caractéristiques essentielles de l'image
et pour faire correctement ce travail,
il faut savoir de quoi on parle.
Dans mon exemple des véhicules, il faut
savoir que ce qui est important
pour différencier un véhicule d'un autre,
c'est le nombre de roue, les vitres, etc...
Donc il faut, entre guillemets, un
expert du domaine.
C'est donc le concepteur de
l'algorithme intermédiaire
qui fait, en quelque sorte, une bonne
partie du travail d'intelligence
et c'est pour pallier à ça qu'intervient le deep learning.
On a vu comment fonctionnait
le machine learning classique
et on a vu comment on pouvait l'utiliser
pour faire de la reconnaissance d'images,
pourvu qu'on ait une étape précédente
qui soit une étape de construction
des caractéristiques essentielles de l'image qu'on
pourrait ensuite donner à un réseau de neurones.
L'idée un peu folle du deep learning
c'est de sauter cette étape.
En gros, on va faire un gros réseau
avec plein de couches de neurones
à qui on file l'image brute.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un réseau
profond,
d'où l'appellation d'apprentissage profond,
ou deep learning en anglais.
Je vous ai dit, a priori cette idée ne peut pas fonctionner,
ça fait beaucoup trop de neurones,
ça fait beaucoup trop de boutons à tourner
et la phase d'apprentissage ne marche pas.
Et bien, il y a quand même
des gens qui ont voulu essayer.
Un de ces pionniers, c'est un français
qui s'appelle Yann Le Cun
et qui a commencé à utiliser ces
méthodes dans les années 90.
A l'époque la communauté de l'intelligence
artificielle n'était pas du tout convaincue
et préférait s'intéresser à d'autres trucs.
Pendant à peu près deux décennies il n'y a eu
qu'une poignée de personnes dans le monde
qui ont continuer à essayer de faire du deep learning.
Sauf qu'en 2012 il y a eu une explosion.
Il faut savoir que tous les ans, il y a une compétition
de reconnaissance d'images qui est organisée
où tous les meilleurs algorithmes
du monde s'affrontent.
vous pouvez voir ici les pourcentages d'erreurs obtenus
par les différents algorithmes de la compétition
en 2010 et en 2011
et plus ce pourcentage est faible,
meilleur est l'algorithme.
Et bien en 2012, à la surprise générale,
c'est un algorithme de deep learning
qui a largement battu tout le monde
et dès l'année suivante, tout le monde s'est mis
à faire du deep learning dans cette compétition.
Evidemment, ce qui est intéressant
c'est d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi,
soudainement, un algorithme de deep learning
marche mieux que les méthodes habituelles,
alors que pendant 20 ans tout le monde
avait pensé que ça ne marcherait jamais.
On l'a dit, dans les méthodes habituelles
on a un algorithme qui extrait de l'image
les caractéristiques essentielles, qui résume l'image,
qui en donne une abstraction
et ces caractéristiques, normalement,
on les file à un réseau qui est peu profond.
Le petit miracle qui se produit avec le deep learning,
c'est que si on a réussi à entraîner
le réseau correctement,
on se rend compte que les couches supérieures
contiennent ces caractéristiques essentielles,
tous les éléments importants de l'image
qui peuvent servir à la reconnaître.
C'est à dire que l'algorithme les a
fabriqués lui même, il les a découverts
sans qu'on ait eu besoin de faire le travail pour lui.
Si on reprend l'exemple de la
reconnaissance de véhicules,
ça veut dire qu'on n'aurait pas besoin de dire
à l'algorithme ce que c'est qu'une roue
et le fait qu'une roue c'est important
pour reconnaître un véhicule.
Non, l'algorithme en fait, découvrirait tout seul le concept de roue
et l'importance de la roue pour classifier les véhicules.
Je vous l'ai dit, suite au succès spectaculaire
d'un algorithme de deep learning
dans la compétition de
reconnaissance d'images de 2012,
tout le monde s'est mis à faire du deep learning
et Yann Le Cun qui était resté
entre temps un petit peu dans l'ombre,
est soudainement devenu une des
superstars de l'intelligence artificielle.
Evidemment tout le monde s'est mis à
embaucher des spécialistes de deep learning,
Google, Amazon, Baidu, etc... et bien sûr Facebook
qui a embauché Le Cun comme directeur
de son laboratoire d'intelligence artificielle.
Ce que je n'ai pas encore dit,
c'est pourquoi cette méthode
à laquelle personne ne croyait
il y a encore quelques années
s'est mise à marcher soudainement.
Et bien, comme souvent, il y a plusieurs raisons.
D'abord les algorithmes ont progressé, comme toujours,
notamment, contrairement à ce que je peux laisser
penser, on n'utilise pas n'importe quel réseau profond,
ce n'est pas juste un tas de neurones empilés
et on a des architectures
particulières qui fonctionnent bien.
Il y a aussi bien sûr une raison matérielle,
c'est la puissance de calcul
et notamment les progrès des processeurs
de cartes graphiques, les GPU,
qui sont plus puissants que les processeurs traditionnels
quand il s'agit de faire des choses liées à l'image.
Mais la vraie raison du succès des algorithmes de
deep learning notamment en reconnaissance d'images,
ça a été la disponibilité des données.
Je vous ai dit, quand on fait un réseau profond
on peut se retrouver avec des milliers,
voire des millions de neurones
et donc ça peut faire des millions
de boutons qu'il faut tourner
pendant la phase d'apprentissage
jusqu'à trouver la bonne relation.
Pour faire ça, il faut des millions
d'exemples à montrer au réseau.
En 2009 un laboratoire de Stanford a rendu public
une base de données qui s'appelle ImageNet
et qui contient aujourd'hui plus de
15 millions d'images classifiées,
c'est à dire qu'on a des images et en face de
chaque image, on a une description de ce que c'est,
c'est à dire, une voiture, un chien, une vague, etc...
Il y a plus de 10000 catégories différentes
alors vous pouvez faire le test
et vous pouvez chercher dans ImageNet
par exemple, les images qui représentent un chat
et je crois qu'il y en a plusieurs dizaines de milliers.
Donc quand on balance toutes ces images
à un algorithme de deep learning
on n'a pas besoin de lui dire quelles
sont les caractéristiques essentielles
qui font qu'un chat est un chat.
La forme de la tête, la couleur des yeux,
la taille des oreilles, etc...
L'algorithme va les découvrir tout seul.
A l'heure actuelle on peut faire des réseaux
profonds qui ont plus d'une centaine de couches
et plusieurs millions de neurones.
On est encore très très loin du cerveau
mais les performances en reconnaissance
d'images sont quand même assez spectaculaires.
Vous pouvez voir quelques exemples ici...
Quand on sait que chaque jour sur Facebook c'est
près de 800 millions d'images qui sont uploadées,
on comprend bien leur intérêt pour avoir un algorithme
qui soit capable de reconnaître rapidement
ce qu'il y a dans une photo.
Alors c'est vrai que des fois, ça rate...
Heureusement, il y a d'autres applications
du deep learning que celle d'analyser
les détails graphiques de notre vie privée
qu'on partage sur les réseaux sociaux.
Par exemple, il existe des algorithmes qui sont
capables d'analyser des scènes sur une image
et de les décrire automatiquement par une phrase.
Ça peut être plutôt utile pour les malvoyants.
Une autre application, c'est la conduite autonome,
vous savez, la voiture qui se conduit toute seule
et dont on parle beaucoup en ce moment.
Pour reprendre un exemple qui est donné par Fei Fei Li, qui est une des pionnières de ImageNet,
c'est quand même vachement important
pour une voiture autonome
d'être capable de reconnaître un sac en papier qui est
froissé sur la route et sur lequel elle pourrait rouler,
d'un rocher qui est posé au milieu de la route
et qu'il vaudrait peut-être mieux éviter.
Mais une des applications que je trouve
les plus intéressantes du deep learning,
c'est la capacité à fabriquer des images.
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure, un algorithme
de deep learning, un réseau profond,
si vous lui donnez une image brute en entrée,
il va découvrir tout seul comment résumer cette image
brute par une série de caractéristiques essentielles.
Là je simplifie beaucoup mais, en gros, on peut essayer
de prendre le réseau dans l'autre sens
et de faire en sorte que, si on lui donne
en entrée une série de nombres,
il produise une image en sortie
et cette image sera nouvelle, elle sera unique et aura
les caractéristiques correspondantes à ce qu'on a entré,
mais ce sera une image inventée de toutes pièces.
Les algorithmes qui sont capables de faire ça,
c'est ce qu'on appelle des modèles génératifs.
Par exemple ici, vous voyez un exemple
récent qui est assez spectaculaire,
on a utilisé un modèle génératif
créé par un algorithme de deep learning
pour créer des chambres à coucher.
Vous avez toute une série de chambres à coucher
qui ont été inventées par un algorithme
et ça marche aussi avec des chaises
ou avec des personnages de manga.
Mon exemple préféré, c'est celui-ci:
il s'agit de pochettes d'albums qui ont été complètement
inventées par un algorithme de deep learning
qui auparavant avait étudié
des vraies pochettes d'albums.
L'exemple le plus médiatique, même si
ce n'est pas forcément le plus utile,
c'est celui dont j'ai parlé au début,
c'est Google DeepDream.
Il s'agit d'un réseau qu'on a entrainé
sur tout un tas d'images
et qu'ensuite on a utilisé pour produire
des images un peu psychédéliques.
Le principe est un peu le même que quand on s'amuse
à essayer de trouver des formes dans les nuages,
vous savez, quand on joue à regarder les nuages,
en gros on peut essayer de se forcer
à y voir d'autres trucs que des nuages.
Ici on a donné des images à un réseau profond
et on l'a forcé à essayer d'y voir autre chose
et voilà le résultat. C'est sympa non?
Encore une fois, il s'agit d'un exemple
un peu anecdotique mais j'espère quand même
vous avoir convaincus qu'il y a plein d'applications
fantastiques pour le deep learning
et je suis sûr que d'ici quelques années
on trouvera ce genre d'algorithme partout.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, si vous voulez
aller plus loin je vous en conseille deux autres.
La première c'est celle de Fei Fei Li
qui est une des créatrices de ImageNet,
qui à la conférence TED a présenté
le problème de la reconnaissance d'images
et ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui, c'est assez rapide.
Si vous voulez aller quand même beaucoup plus loin,
vous pouvez aller voir la leçon inaugurale
de Yann Le Cun au Collège de France,
ça dure plus longtemps et il va
beaucoup plus dans les détails.
Comme d'habitude vous pouvez me retrouver
sur les réseaux sociaux, Facebook, Tweeter.
Vous pouvez me soutenir sur Tipeee,
merci à tous les tipeurs qui me soutiennent.
Vous pouvez aussi aller jeter un œil à mon bouquin
que j'ai sorti chez Flammarion
et pour ceux qui sont intéressés à me rencontrer en vrai,
je serai le 16 Avril à Vulgarizators à Lyon,
donc n'hésitez pas à aller voir et n'hésitez pas
à venir assister à toutes les conférences.
Merci et à bientôt!